The Witcher 3 Wild Hunt is already an
enormous sandbox but modders have this
talent of taking a good thing and making
it even better
on that note here are five pretty cool
mods for The Witcher 3 that you should
seriously consider installing should you
be playing it on PC for those of you
hoping the witcher 3 was going to look
more like the trailer we saw at e3 2013
models have come to the rescue set a
project have said the reason for the
graphical deviation from its initial
showing came down to having it look
consistent over consoles and PC but
luckily for PC owners the e3 FX mod by
drogon aims to bring it back to how we
first saw it the mod features improved
texture sharpening and lighting
adjustments for bloom and saturated
colors and the removal of the game's
yellow hue in favor of a colder look if
the darker look of e3 effects isn't your
thing you might also want to take a look
at [ __ ] sushis fantasy graphics mod
which changes a look of the game to a
more colorful high fantasy palette I
find there's nothing worse than having
heaps of awesome loot that you can't
sell off because all the vendors are
horribly poor in RPGs and real-life fine
sure it makes sense for a humble village
merchants to not have a ton of gold and
if you're a fan of sheer practicality
who stops short of installing a gold
sheet because you're a good person you
should check out the wealthy vendors
with fair sale mod by geku man basically
this populates your game world with
loaded vendors who want nothing more
than to trade their sweet shiny gold for
your mountains of crap speaking of
mountains of crap I have two more mods
that might help you out on that front
well one is going to help you out and
the other is probably going to make
things much worse Kuralt may indeed be a
handsome silver fox but he can only
carry so much unfortunately that can
mean cutting your super important
adventuring in half to go back to town
in a deal overburdened pocket the over
9000 wait
limit mod also made by Jessamine
relieves your burdens Lidia style by
letting me turn up he'll carry weight
limit to over 9,000 it's over 9 yeah all
the way up to 9999 if you so choose in
fact if you want to take full advantage
of your new weight limit you may also
want to install the increased creature
loot mod from mines pillar 316 this mod
ensures that monsters and creatures will
always drop at least one piece of loot
and the drop chances for unique hides
and natural ingredients are increased
but this one could be a killer if you
don't have the previous mod installed if
you're one of those people who likes to
mod all the way or not at all then
witcher 3 hunters configure by melek
taus is the one for you
hunters config lets you get right down
to it with a tool for configuring and
tweaking a number of hidden settings in
the game which include audio gameplay
rendering and well basically every
setting you can dream of wanting to
configure if you love tabs and sliders
download hunter's config The Witcher 3
game world is pretty dangerous as it is
but if danger is your middle name and
you want to kick it into overdrive then
you may want to check out extreme
weather conditions by KNG extreme
weather should make you feel like even
more of the batter since now you can
fight off beasties and save maidens in
the pouring rain with low visibility
this mod makes winds stronger clouds
darker and thunderstorms way way more
terrifying
if scary is what you're after though the
Haunted spike island in the middle of a
wild storm is probably your best bet
sauna project red have confirmed that
they'll be releasing official modding
tools for The Witcher 3 before too long
so all this is just the tip of the
iceberg let me know down in that comment
section what mods you'd like to see for
The Witcher 3 and I'll catch again next
week